the falley refinery in southampton it's
the largest in the country usually
receiving oil from all over the world
including russia
but that is changing
vladimir putin over the last
years has been like a pusher
feeding an addiction
in western countries to his hydrocarbons
to his oil and gas
we need to
get ourselves off that addiction that's
why the prime minister is heading to
saudi arabia one of the world's largest
oil producers to discuss alternative
supplies despite concerns over human
rights issues it is politically awkward
but it must be done the uk gets around
eight percent of its oil and four
percent of its gas from russia
boris johnson has promised to end those
oil imports by the end of the year and
dramatically reduce dependence on that
gas
so now he has to find a way to plug that
gap
as a result when the government sets out
its new british energy security strategy
there's likely to be a renewed focus on
drilling in the north sea the fact is
that our economy is overwhelmingly
fossil fuel based so we are going to
burn a lot of fossil fuels for quite a
long time to come
and in the transition
where the renewables which are
incredibly important are intermittent
something's got to back them up
but it's not just about more fossil
fuels as the uk's energy mix from last
month illustrates
nuclear power made up 14.4 percent and
renewables wind hydro and solar combined
made up nearly 45.
what's important about this moment is
that we set ourselves a course as fast
as possible to get to zero emissions as
fast as possible to take ourselves out
of the problems that fossil fuels cause
fossil fuels cause air pollution they
cause climate change they're driving
conflict as part of its new strategy the
government is going to make commitments
to renewables and nuclear power viewed
as the only long-term way to help reduce
energy prices increase energy security
and tackle climate change
but these things will take time to ramp
up and so for the moment there is little
choice no fossil fuel from russia means
difficult choices about where else to
get it
hannah thomas peter sky news in
southampton